hey guys a smack smack stack and in this
video I'm gonna be talking about the top
five problems with the new iPad pro
apple just released the new iPad pro and
beforehand
the rumors were coming out about all the
new devices and this was the one that I
was least excited about after the event
was over though the iPad pro is what I'm
actually now most excited for and yes we
are getting one in so make sure you hit
that subscribe button and while you're
down there don't forget to hit that Bell
notifications icon as well now even
though this is the biggest update to the
iPad pro ever and that a 12 X Bionic
processor is ridiculously powerful
beating out even the most expensive
15-inch MacBook Pro from 2017 it's not
all rainbows and butterflies here are
the top 5 problems with the new iPad pro
number one is going to be the price the
new 11 inch version which is an update
to the 10 and 1/2 inch version cost one
hundred and fifty dollars more and if
you want the larger twelve point nine
inch version nothing is $1,000 starting
price so $200 more expensive than the
previous model I feel really bad to
anybody who just spent a bunch of money
on a ten and a half inch iPad pro and
now you have a new model that's really
updated but costs way more money Apple
is doing a fantastic job upping their
prices on all of their devices across
the board and Apple is already known for
having expensive products now if you're
a shareholder or you have stock or
anything like that you should be very
happy because the average sales price is
shooting way up there especially thanks
to the new iPhone 10 and 10's Mac's to
make this an even bigger point Apple
just had their earnings call and there
they announced that they will no longer
be releasing volume numbers for sales of
iPhones and iPads and their other
devices because sales numbers don't
matter as much as they used to now
that's because all of their devices are
more expensive so even though they're
not selling as many their profits are
through the roof number two is that
you're going to have to buy the new
Apple pencil now yes the new one is a
great design it's a really big update
you have some gestures on there it's
magnetic it attaches to the side of the
iPad and it also charges and syncs that
way but you do have to buy that one you
can no longer use the standard Apple
pencil that you just spent $100 on this
is a nice device but it is very pricey
and I would have loved to see Apple
still have backwards compatibility for
this and not everybody can afford to buy
another one if you just spent that much
money
especially with the new iPads costing
that much more so this makes a larger
barrier to entry to upgrading to the new
iPad pro now I know they no longer have
a lightning jack on the new iPad but
they could have maybe sold another
adapter for nine dollars like they are
with a new USBC 2 headphone adapter and
just allowed you to use this or it maybe
even better just plug it into your
iPhone have it synced to the iCloud like
your other Bluetooth devices and then
have it sync with the iPad so you know
if you're already spending a bunch of
money and you don't have the budget for
it maybe you can wait half a year or a
year whenever you can afford to buy the
new one so sucks especially if you've
just picked up one of these hundred
dollar Apple pencils number three is
going to be the RAM now this isn't
completely confirmed yet but there's a
lot of sources talking about that
there's a six gigabyte version of the
iPad pro but in order to get six gigs of
ram you have to buy the one terabyte
option that means spending around $1,500
for the 11 inch and $1,700 for the
twelve point nine inch ipad pro's the
base ones will come most likely with
four gigabytes of RAM and if you want
the higher-end model you have to spend
that crazy amount of money now sure iOS
is very optimized and it doesn't need as
much RAM as Android devices but if
you're buying such an expensive pro
device that is supposed to replace your
desktop or your laptop computer I would
definitely want to have six gigs of RAM
especially now that we have very
powerful kind of desktop grade apps like
the new Lightroom and the new Photoshop
that they showed off on stage I'm fairly
certain that the lady that I was showing
a Photoshop with like a hundred and
seventy different layers and using a are
she was probably using the top and model
with six gigs of RAM so now that we have
these capabilities and it's becoming
much more powerful device and we have
crazy CPU and graphics performance I
would like to see six gigs of RAM all
across the board sure your iPhone has a
four gigs ram if you buy the expensive
model but you're not doing 170 layers of
Photoshop on your phone and then if we
look at some other devices like this new
guy right here the oneplus 60 which
starts at five hundred eighty dollars
for the eight gigabyte of ram model
obviously they're making a profit here
and this is a cell phone so if you're
solving an iPad pro please give a six
gigs of RAM all across the board just in
case we do want to use it for what
you're advertising it
number four might be the biggest deal
a lot of you guys and that's the fact
that the new iPad pros no longer have a
headphone jack now it was a little bit
more lenient to an Apple when they
removed it from iPhones they wanted to
make space for other features larger
battery stuff like that and you have a
very small device but the iPad pros are
quite large so there's definitely space
for a headphone jack not only that on
the stage they showed off like DJ
equipment being used and plugged into
the iPad so if you're a DJ wouldn't you
want to have a headphone jack that can
output really good quality audio instead
of relying on Bluetooth or a bunch of
adapters that just makes a lot of sense
to have that in this device I think
Apple just at this point just wants to
sell their Bluetooth stuff and I'm not
certain about this yet but the new USBC
it's a headphone adapter that they sell
on their website most likely won't be
included with the iPad just like if you
buy an $1100 iPhone they no longer
include that adapter as well number five
is a new more expensive keyboard case
you no longer have that slim vertical
standing mode like you did with the
previous case in the previous Smart
Cover now this was very useful if you
have a limited amount of counter space
and you want to be able to watch a video
or do something else without having to
take up a larger space with the keyboard
fold it out now you do have two modes
with the new keyboard case so you can
kind of adjust your angle but the case
seems like it's longer now and that way
you always have to have it opened up if
you want your iPad to be open and
standing there so you can watch
something now if you don't need the
keyboard thankfully you could still buy
the smart folio which now does cover the
back and it also allows you to put it
into that vertical orientation and not
take up a lot of room but unfortunately
it does cost more now which kind of
makes sense but you cannot get it in a
premium leather version like you could
in the past so now you can only get it
in plastic and it costs $10 more than
the previous premium leather version now
I'm going to add in one more thing as a
bonus and that is the camera so we have
the same sensor and lens from the iPhone
10s and the 10 hour and the 10s max so
we do have a really nice quality camera
and it also has all those smart HDR
features which are fantastic
now I'm not somebody that goes out and
shoots a bunch of photos with an iPad
but if you take a look at the iPad and
what they were showing off a lot of
people take shots of documents and
they're also maybe doing some video
they're recording some ARS
and one downside with that camera is you
no longer have optical image
stabilization now my guess is they
remove the optical image stabilization
just to make it a little bit thinner and
maybe smaller and that way the camera
bump isn't as large but if you are gonna
be recording video optical image
stabilization really helps and also if
you take photos in some lower light
conditions let's say you're scanning a
document inside your house it really
helps to stabilize the image so you get
very nice sharp result so I definitely
think that they should have left this in
even if it meant making a camera of up
slightly thicker either way you can't
lay this thing down perfectly flat on
your desk even though it's like the
perfect shape and designed to be able to
do so because of the camera bump that's
already there so if we're already
dealing with a camera bump and a little
bit of wobble when you put it down on
your desk why not make it just slightly
thicker and have optical image
stabilization just like your iPhones now
what these top five were actually six
problems of the iPad pro I want to say
that I'm still very excited for this
device if you guys bought one or you're
going to buy one let me know in the
comment section below and if you know of
any other problems or anything else that
bugs you about this device also comment
below I'm excited to hear your guys's
opinions
now with that new design and we have
faced ID and that crazy powerful
processor which has eight cores and
seven cores for the graphics along with
all these new apps this is really
looking like a very compelling device
and the first one that really makes me
kind of believe in the whole prospect of
an iPad pro being able to replace let's
say a laptop or a desktop so we do have
one coming in we'll be comparing it to a
macbook and seeing
can it actually replace your macbook so
make sure you guys are subscribed that
you have the little notifications well
enabled that's been Max and I will see
you in the next video